para que puedan ver la luz en movimiento.
Coca-Cola no auspició esta investigación. (Risas)
Ocurren muchas cosas en esta película;
desglosaré esta información para mostrar qué está pasando.
El pulso, nuestra bala, entra en la botella
con un paquete de fotones que empieza a atravesarla
y que, dentro, empieza a dispersarse.
Parte de la luz se fuga, va a la mesa,
y empezamos a ver estas ondulaciones.
Muchos de los fotones finalmente llegan a la tapa
y luego explotan en varias direcciones.
Como pueden ver, hay una burbuja de aire
que rebota en el interior.
En ese tiempo, las ondas viajan por la mesa
y debido a las reflexiones de la parte superior
se ve en el fondo de la botella, después de varios cuadros,
que las reflexiones se concentran.
Ahora, si tomamos una bala común y corriente
y hacemos que recorra la misma distancia y la vemos en cámara lenta
a unas 10 mil millones de veces, ¿cuánto piensan
que nos llevaría sentarnos a ver esa película?
¿Un día? ¿Una semana? En realidad, todo un año.
Sería una película muy aburrida (Risas)
de una lenta bala en movimiento.
¿Y qué tal probar con naturaleza muerta?
Pueden ver las ondas que se apoderan de la mesa,
del tomate y de la pared del fondo.
Es como arrojar una piedra en un estanque.
Es la forma en que la naturaleza pinta una foto, pensaba,
de un femtocuadro a la vez,
pero, claro, nuestros ojos ven una composición integral.
Pero si miran una vez más este tomate,
se darán cuenta de que, a medida que la luz se apodera del tomate,
sigue brillante. No se oscurece.
¿Por qué? Porque el tomate está maduro
y la luz rebota en su interior
y vuelve a salir luego de varias billonésimas de segundo.
En el futuro, cuando esta femtocámara
esté en sus móviles,
van a poder ir al supermercado
y verificar si la fruta está madura sin tener que tocarla.
¿Para qué creamos esta cámara en el MIT?
Como fotógrafos, ya saben,
si tomamos una foto a baja exposición, entra muy poca luz,
pero iremos mil millones de veces más rápido
que la exposición más corta,
así que apenas entrará algo de luz.
Mandamos esa bala,
ese paquete de fotones, millones de veces,
y grabamos una y otra vez con una sincronización muy astuta,
tomamos esos gigabytes de datos
y los entrelazamos computacionalmente
para crear esos femtovideos que les mostré.
Podemos tomar todos esos datos en crudo
y procesarlos de manera interesante.
Superman puede volar.
Otros héroes pueden volverse invisibles,
¿y si un nuevo poder de un futuro superhéroe
le permitiera ver tras los rincones?
La idea es que podríamos arrojar algo de luz sobre la puerta.
Rebotará, entrará a la habitación,
una parte se va a reflejar en la puerta,
y desde allí hasta la cámara,
de donde podríamos extraer esos múltiples rebotes de luz.
No es ciencia ficción. Ya lo hemos construido.
A la izquierda, está nuestra femtocámara.
Detrás de la pared hay un maniquí
y rebotaremos la luz en la puerta.
Luego de la publicación de nuestro artículo
en Nature Communications,
Nature.com lo destacó
y creó esta animación.
(Música)
Dispararemos esas balas de luz,
que impactarán en esta pared,
y debido al paquete de fotones
se esparcirán en todas direcciones,
y algunas alcanzarán al maniquí oculto
que a su vez dispersará esa luz
y nuevamente la puerta reflejará
parte de esa luz dispersada,
y una fracción pequeña de los fotones
regresará a la cámara pero, curiosamente,
en momentos levemente diferentes.
(Música)
Y como tenemos una cámara que funciona así de rápido,
nuestra femtocámara, tiene capacidades únicas.
Tiene muy buena resolución temporal
y puede mirar al mundo a la velocidad de la luz.
Así, conocemos las distancias hasta la puerta
y también hasta los objetos ocultos
pero no sabemos qué punto corresponde
a qué distancia.
(Música)
Al proyectar un láser se puede grabar una foto en bruto, que,
ven en la pantalla, realmente no tiene ningún sentido,
pero tomaremos muchas imágenes así,
decenas de imágenes, las juntaremos
y trataremos de analizar los múltiples rebotes de luz,
y con eso, ¿podremos ver el objeto oculto?
¿Podremos verlo en 3D?
Esta es nuestra reconstrucción. (Música)
(Música)
(Música) (Aplausos)
Tenemos cosas por explorar antes de sacar esto
del laboratorio, pero en el futuro,
podríamos crear autos que eviten colisiones
con lo que está a la vuelta de la curva,
o podríamos buscar sobrevivientes en condiciones peligrosas
mirando la luz reflejada por las ventanas abiertas,
o podríamos construir endoscopios capaces de ver
el interior del cuerpo sorteando oclusores,
y lo mismo para los cardioscopios.
Pero, claro, debido al tejido y la sangre
esto es bastante difícil, así que en realidad esto es un pedido
a los científicos para que empiecen a pensar en la femtofotografía
como una nueva modalidad de visualización
para solucionar los problemas de imagenología en salud de la próxima generación.
Así como Doc Edgerton, él mismo un científico,
convirtió la ciencia en arte, un arte de fotografías ultrarrápidas,
me di cuenta de que todos los gigabytes de datos
que recolectamos cada vez
no son solo para visualizaciones científicas, sino que podemos
crear una nueva forma de fotografía computacional
con cámara lenta y código de colores,
y miremos esas ondas. Recuerden,
el tiempo entre cada una de esas ondas es de solo
unas billonésimas de segundo.
Pero aquí también ocurre algo divertido.
Si miramos las ondas debajo de la tapa,
estas se alejan de nosotros.
Las ondas deberían moverse hacia nosotros.
¿Qué ocurre aquí?
Resulta que, como estamos grabando
casi a la velocidad de la luz,
tenemos efectos extraños.
A Einstein le habría encantado ver esta imagen.
El orden en que ocurren los eventos en el mundo
a veces aparece invertido ante la cámara.
Aplicando la deformación correspondiente de espacio y tiempo,
podemos corregir esta distorsión.
Ya sea en la fotografía tras los rincones,
o en la próxima generación de imagenología en salud,
o en nuevas visualizaciones,
puesto que nuestra invención es de código abierto,
todos los datos y los detalles están en nuestro sitio web y esperamos
que la comunidad de investigación, los creativos y amateurs
nos muestren que deberíamos dejar de obsesionarnos
con los megapíxeles en las cámaras —(Risas)—
y empezar a centrarnos en la próxima dimensión en imagenología.
Ya es tiempo. Gracias. (Aplausos)
(Aplausos)